christmas three days away but with the
rise of the omicron yes that part of
this virus health officials and some
democrats want to make some big
last-minute changes to your family
get-togethers president biden and dr
fauci say you should only celebrate with
family members that are vaccinated if
they're not they want you to tell those
relatives to stay home alone
i know some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those you celebrate with are
vaccinated
if someone in your family isn't
vaccinated should you ask them not to
show up
uh yes i would do that i mean i think
we're dealing with a serious enough
situation right now that if there's an
unvaccinated person i would say i'm very
sorry but not this time maybe another
time when this is all over yeah that's
fine for the fouchy family we can make
our own decisions you think that was bad
but i guess it's better than the whl the
world health organization what they're
pushing they don't want us to celebrate
at all
an event cancelled is better
than a life cancelled
it's better to cancel now and celebrate
later than to celebrate now and grieve
later
i wonder if he'll be celebrating in
china they seem to love him there don't
these so-called experts realize there is
more harm than in not getting together
with family again we already know the
cases of depression and anxiety are on
the rise because of this pandemic so
telling people they can't see their
loved ones for christmas for the second
consecutive year is a psychological
crisis i believe joining me right now to
give a better perspective is it true
from two of them psychiatrists and
former mental health policy fellow in
the u.s senate dr daniel bober and
florida congressman byron donalds
welcome to both of you first dr bober
don't you think that you should have a
say in this the mental and emotional
health of americans on christmas it's
more than just presence isn't it
well you know these public health
recommendations have definitely taken a
mental health toll we know that crisis
mental health visits for kids are up by
75 percent an increase in suicidal
ideation by 20 percent overdoses that
are
skyrocketing to up to a hundred thousand
so there's definitely another side to
this besides just the infection itself
which is why i think that dr fauci
should stay out of our family
get-togethers he's already on way too
many sunday shows congressman donalds
are you surprised because you're in
florida it's easy to be isolated where
you live in the land of the free that
we're talking about shutting down
christmas again
you know i'm actually a little surprised
and here's why because i figured the
left would have learned already that
people are sick of lockdowns they're
sick of mandates they're sick of being
told what to do by people who don't even
follow their own rules how many more
pictures of videos do we need to see of
joe biden nancy pelosi jan saki dr fauci
telling us to do something then we catch
them not doing it themselves but
unfortunately they're so committed to
their plan well frankly they're
non-planned they're so committed to that
because they failed everywhere else they
have nowhere else to go but this is
insane people want to be together people
are not meant to be isolated it's a bad
situation for our country we need to
stop with the mandates and the lockdowns
we need to actually just go back to
battling the pandemic with actual data
with actual science hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else